my name is Nicole Carlton my pronouns
are she her and hers and there's my
email and Twitter handle if you want and
today I'm going to be talking to you
about app iceberg cautionary tale and
titled how to spend three-quarters of
your yearly budget in three weeks and
it's actually even worse than that it's
how to spend three-quarters of your
team's yearly budget in three weeks not
just the money that's allocated for you
so the way this talk will work I'll tell
you about the problem I was trying to
solve the disaster that took place and
what I should have done differently I
work for a company called shop runner
we're an online network of about 140
retailers including companies like
Newegg staples Saks Fifth Avenue our
members get free two-day shipping and
free returns from our partners and as a
company we add code to the retailer
websites and we provide them with
marketing tools like personalized emails
out of stock notifications a bunch of
different stuff I actually have free
membership cards so come see me
afterwards if you want a free one-year
membership since we're in the retail
space one of the first projects for the
data science team was to come up with
some way to recommend similar products
so in this example if somebody has
viewed this kick boot gene we want to be
able to recommend other products we
think they'll like and we decided to
start with a relatively simple approach
which was cosine similarity based on
orders data so our orders data lived in
a database in a table roughly like this
so one column is the members the other
column is the products that they
purchased we then take this orders data
read it in from the database and work in
spark so once we have this orders data
we turn it into a member product
interaction matrix the rows are the
members the columns are the products we
put a one where somebody has bought that
product is zero otherwise so you might
imagine this ends up being a pretty
sparse matrix because most people do not
buy most things then the way we find
similar products is by comparing the
columns with one another and the
specific measure we used was cosine
similarity
so you can imagine that these columns
live in a high dimensional vector space
where the dimensionality is the number
of members and then you compare the
angle between them they're pointing the
same direction the ink the similarity
will be one if they're at right angles
the similarity will be zero and since
our interaction matrix was only made of
zeros and ones our similarities will
only be between 0 & 1 we won't have any
negative values this graphic is from a
blog called data aspirant by somebody
named Simon do you pull and miri kung fu
panda has nothing to do with the rest of
the talk I just really like this graphic
a lot so as I mentioned my company was
using Pais Burk we have a lot of data we
knew we wanted to work in parallel and
in particular we use PI SPARC on top of
data bricks data breaks is an online
platform for running SPARC clusters they
have their own notebooks you can run on
top of them
and you can schedule jobs and there's
some other nice features our data lived
in snowflake which is a new relational
database and some of it also lived in
Amazon s3 so I worked on this with my
coworker Hana and first we we did all of
our work in a day to Brick's notebook
then when we were satisfied that
everything was working the way we
expected we put it into a nice Python
package you know with classes and
functions and all your favorite Python
stuff but we're good Python programmers
so we wrote unit tests Hana is actually
giving a talk about unit tests in a few
sessions you should check that out so we
had good code we had unit tests we had
our cluster ready to go so we were ready
to find similar products by orders and
it worked really well
it worked great I think better than
anybody on the data science team
expected so here you see those same kick
boot jeans and you see that we're
recommending other kick boot jeans
other types of pants top but they all
kind of look like they're the same style
so it looks pretty good and we were
super happy about this but one issue
with orders is that some products are
never ordered or very rarely ordered so
we can't recommend other similar items
for those products
so for our next iteration we decided to
use member pageviews
so since we have code on our partners
sites we know what products our members
are viewing and most people view a lot
more products than they actually
purchase so it's the same general
structure we have some data where one
column is members the other column is
the products that they viewed and in our
case this was about a thousand times
larger than the orders data so we're
feeling pretty good about this our code
was still in the Python package still
unit tested made our clusters ready to
go and at this point the code had been
functionally tested with orders so we
were pretty confident that it would be
super easy so all I had to do is use a
new data source Hannah and I wrote this
similarity job class so that was really
flexible we knew we were gonna have to
do a bunch of these types of jobs so all
I had to do was swap out the data source
so orders for member views no problem
very easy right
no it turns out it was not easy so this
data set was much larger and the the job
was taking a lot longer to run like
eight hours and all of a sudden I
started getting this super weird
intermittent iceberg error but I did not
understand at all sometimes have it
happen like an hour into the job
sometimes for hours sometimes seven
hours sometimes it would be the very
last step which is super painful but had
no idea what's going on if you haven't
seen a PI spark stack trace they're
pretty gnarly and terrible and I'll let
you live through that with me so you get
back a bunch of stuff from all the
workers and the driver and I don't think
humans can read it you probably have to
be a robot and they just go on and on
and on and on and on and actually you
can see at the bottom it says one more
so the stack trees is so long that they
can't even return it all to us so
obviously I had no idea what's happening
this is impossible for a human to read
the part of the stack trace that seemed
relevant to me was this thing the
provided token has expired
something about s3 so as I mentioned
some of our data lived in s3 so I assume
that for some reason we're hitting some
limit that we hadn't seen with orders
and I thought well I guess I just have
to make everything faster so we don't
hit this limit so here are the ideas I
came up with to speed things up and
avoid the s3 timeout error
I was pretty new to PI spark so these
are kind of my naive ideas so my first
idea was just run it again and I kind of
hoped that the problem was with data
bricks or AWS and not my code and that
miraculously everything would just work
I also thought maybe there's so much
more data that I just need to add more
nodes and somehow this will fix
everything right more nodes more
parallel great I also considered
increasing the individual node sighs
maybe the nodes just weren't powerful
enough for some reason I don't know and
maybe I should just try all this at the
same time and everything will be great I
wasn't a complete fool though I know
that PI star clusters cost money more
than just running stuff on my laptop so
I went to my boss explained the problem
I have witnesses to this conversation
and ones in the front row and so I was
like hey it's what's going on these are
the ideas I have so you know how big my
clusters be and he said as big as you
want don't worry about it like there's
no way you're gonna spend too much money
like just we have to solve this problem
so just go for it this is a giant carrot
in New Zealand it's the primary reason I
went to New Zealand I highly recommend
you check it out forever there it's
amazing so had a bunch of ideas had
permission to spend a bunch of money you
know everything was looking good three
weeks later so this is a graph of our
cluster usage over time as you may have
guessed from this graph I was working on
this in March you can see that I spent
way more money in March than we in any
prior months or any subsequent months
again this is the team budget not just
the money that I was spending so I think
the first lesson to take from this is if
your boss tells you you have unlimited
resources they're wrong it's not true it
doesn't matter where you work if you're
at a two-person startup if you're at
Google you're running that 10,000 node
cluster they mentioned this morning and
the Giulia talk there's some upper limit
and additionally at one point my boss
told me that I was spending 72 dollars
an hour but the problem is I had no idea
what that meant like is that a lot or a
little four clusters I have no idea so
along with realizing there's an upper
limit to how much you can spend you
should figure out what scale of cost is
appropriate for your company and if
you're a manager you should definitely
impart this information to your
employees otherwise you're gonna have to
make graphs like this in the future all
right so what should we have done
I was pretty new to Pais back when I was
working on this now that I'm six months
older and wiser I realized there's a
number of things we could have done
differently so the rest of this talk
will be me giving you some PI spark
suggestions and at the end I'll explain
the actual error that we ran into all
right
first suggestion is pretty simple and
that is check on your cluster and
database usage so here you can see a
snowflake bots are they the engineering
team set up every day it messages the
data science team tells us how many
credits we used how many credits we have
remaining they set this up in April I'm
sure that was entirely coincidental to
me spending the money in March so if you
can set up automated reports like this
if you can't just set a calendar
reminder just check it may seem like
kind of a waste of time but had me even
checked a week into my spending spree we
still would have saved a significant
amount of money I would've at a talk but
the company would probably think that
was better
all right another thing I should have
done was test with a smaller data set I
was feeling really good after the orders
worked super well
so I figured I should just throw all the
member page use that the problem and I
think this is something a lot of data
scientists do we have this fantasy that
the very first model we run will work
perfectly and we won't have to make any
adjustments so we might as well just
throw everything at it the first time I
don't know why I believe this it's never
true it's never been true for anyone but
I still want to do it with spark that's
a really bad idea though because your
data size can matter a lot the same code
that works with a smaller set of data
may not run with a larger set you may
have to change things to run so it would
have been better if I'd started with a
subset of the member views and slowly
scaled the data up to make sure the code
was working the way I expected it to all
right this one's really particular to PI
spark and that is partitioning your data
appropriately we started out with orders
we were just using the default values
for spark so when you read in some data
spark decides how it wants to partition
your data seems to be based on the
number of files how many workers it has
some mysterious formula in a lot of
cases it works really well when you get
to larger sets of data it doesn't always
do a very good job
and the suggestion we've heard from data
breaks is to not have more than 256
megabytes per partition so you can use a
formula like this so first to figure out
how many megabytes you have per row this
is if you have growing data right every
day people are viewing more products so
we didn't have a static number of rows
so cache it save it to disk to memory
whatever figure out how big your data is
multiply the number of rows tone there's
megabytes per partition and divide by
the max megabytes you want to have per
partition so relatively straightforward
that's something you may not be aware of
as a new PI spark user if the defaults
have just worked well for you in the
past
all right another thing I didn't realize
is that good Python code can be really
hard to debug in PI spark so here you
can see the code from one of our
similarity jobs first we instantiate an
instance of that similarity job class we
generate the recs we call the right Rex
2d ease method and everything is done
that's the whole job and it's so
beautiful it's so elegant it's so simple
but if there's a problem you're gonna
have no idea what's going on there's a
ton of logic packed into each line of
code so if you run into errors like
super gnarly ones that you can't figure
out I would suggest that you unpack all
of your nice functions and classes and
run each line of code separately in a
notebook this kind of feel is
counterintuitive and it feels wrong
after you spent all the work trying to
to make everything nice but it will
actually save you time it along in the
long run and if something my boss always
tells me to do and I always resist and
then a week later I end up doing it
anyway so learn from my mistakes and
just do it right away and in particular
with PI spark you're gonna want to run
each step separately when you're
debugging and I'll go through this
example in a minute but the reason why
is because spark does something called
lazy evaluation so when you call it
transformation like multiplying two
columns or capitalizing a string column
or whatever it's not actually executed
until some action is called so one
common action is count like figuring how
big your data frame is another one is
take taking a row from the data frame
collect collecting stuff to data
whatever so if you set up a bunch of
transformations and don't call an action
spark tries to optimize everything so
that all the transformations are run in
the best way possible and sometimes this
works out really nicely and sometimes it
makes things really confusing so on the
left you can see that I'm taking some
data frame DF I turn it into a
coordinate matrix I turned that into a
row matrix and then I called column
similarities on that row matrix the red
indicates that there's an error so it
looks like there's an error during this
map tupple phase on the right you can
see a split all of the
steps out first I turn the data frame
into a coordinate matrix I take a row
from that and it works so that's an
option so things are executed I then
take that coordinate matrix and turn
into a row matrix try and take a row
from that and that's where the error is
actually taking place so if you don't
execute your transformations it'll it
can be very hard to figure out which one
is actually causing the issue in your
code and this is another thing that
feels kind of wrong like all you really
care about is the last step usually so
you're probably like well why do I need
to execute all these things I don't
really care about them because it will
save you time and money all right it'll
it'll just make your debugging a lot
easier if you can be sure that each line
of code is working the way that you
expect it to similarly I suggest that
you save intermediate steps to Amazon s3
or whatever other cheap storage space
you have HDFS I don't know Google
probably has something so writing the s3
is an action like count or take so that
will cause your transformations to be
executed and if you save your
intermediate steps you'll have them to
look back on later especially with super
long jobs that may run overnight so for
example the first step and our
similarity job takes like two hours per
run so if there's a bug and we come in
in the morning we don't wanna have to
wait two hours to get to that first step
so if we have a bunch of intermediate
steps saved we can immediately start
debugging and make sure that things are
working the way we want to and this is
another thing where it may feel like you
shouldn't be wasting the storage but
it'll save you debugging time and s3 is
pretty cheap so why not
okay but switch gears a little bit and
talk about JDBC connectors JDBC stands
for Java database connectivity it's an
API for how Java clients access
databases so when you're working with PI
spark spark we'll try and get data from
the database it'll send the requests
through the connector the connector will
talk to the database and the database
will send the data back through the
connector and one issue with JDBC
connectors is that by default most of
them will just open one connection
obviously this is not very useful for
spark because a bunch of your workers
will be sitting around idle so you have
to manually control how many connections
you open but if you open too many
connections are gonna be hammering the
database and that's gonna cause its own
problems so we talked to data bricks
about this and at first they just said
don't use JDBC connectors ever obviously
that's not practical for a lot of us who
use databases so their second piece of
advice was to remove JDBC connectors as
soon as possible by saving your data to
s3 so here you get on a side you can see
I've loaded some orders data from
snowflake I immediately write it to s3
and then I read the orders back in and
from then on we work with the read and
orders data frame and I haven't really
seen this piece of advice in any
documentation online I'm not sure why it
seems super important and I feel like
everyone should know about it but just
cut out your database entirely get rid
of the connector as soon as possible so
now whenever my team runs PI spec code
we immediately write the results to s3
and they read them back in before doing
anything with them
all right at this point you may be
wondering what was causing that s3
expired token error and had I followed
the six suggestions I've given you so
far actually what a sidestep the heir
entirely I wouldn't have seen it at all
so I never would have figured out what's
going on on my own and actually we had
to work with data bricks to understand
what's happening and I didn't want to
use the same graphic so I flipped it I
thought that'd be different enough all
right so the secret to what happened is
buried in that gnarly stack trace and
showed you earlier I don't know if any
of you caught it maybe you're really
good at reading stack traces so here you
can see within the stack trace
there's something about snowflake when I
told you about the job earlier I
mentioned that the first thing we did
was read the data in from the database
and then all the calculations were in
spark this error was coming up to four
six hours into the job so snowflakes
should be gone by then so if we
shouldn't be doing anything all of the
errors should be involved with PI spark
and it turns out there's some issues
with the snowflake JDBC connector and
one way we can see this is by looking at
caching so first I'll show you how spark
caching is supposed to work here I have
some orders data that's been read in
from s3 on the bottom you can see I've
called cache on it and this command
takes no time at all
so with cash you're basically just
telling SPARC hey the next time you use
this data frame save it to disk or
memory so that it doesn't have to be
recalculated again so the next time an
action is called on it so it is a lazy
operation right nothing should be
happening at all and this is the way we
expect things to work
in contrast let's look at caching on
data that's been read in from the
snowflake JDBC connector so I've loaded
in that orders data and then I call
cache and you can see this time the
command has taken 45 seconds and that
should confuse you that doesn't make any
sense so as I mentioned that's a lazy
operation it should take no time at all
and what we discovered is that the
snowflake JDBC connector confuses the
spark optimizer sometimes and causes it
to read in the data multiple times even
when it shouldn't so the connector will
keep we triggering database calls even
when it's already read in the
information at this point you may think
well that's fine that would kind of suck
it would just make your job run longer
though so you know we read the data and
we get six hours into the calculation
then all of a sudden decides read it in
again and then it goes through all the
calculations again that's not fun but it
will just take a longer time but it
turns out that additionally there was a
secret s3 temp storage timeout that
snowflake had set and this was a setting
that snowflake controlled entirely our
admins had no way of seeing in and when
you're trying to pull the data into PI
spark from snowflakes through the
connector it turns out that snowflake
temporarily stores things in s3 so we
were reading the data in our
calculations are taking a super long
time and so we're hitting their 60
minute timeout that we had no control
over so this was the actual underlying
cause so their connector was causing
rereads from the database and their temp
storage how to timeout that we had no
control over and so all of a sudden of
different points in my calculation in
our job we would be hitting there as
three timeout error so I find a piece of
advice for you if the first six don't
work and you solve weird errors is to
ask your vendors if they have any
unexposed settings for example time outs
this can feel kind of contrary to
regular Python coding so usually you
trust your connectors you trust
third-party libraries
but in our case we're working with
snowflake and they're of very new
technology so it's not surprising that
their code has some bugs we all have
bugs and when you're working with this
really new stuff you often have to code
more defensively than you would
otherwise and in some cases there may be
settings that they haven't realized that
their end users might need access to so
it's worth checking out if there's
anything like that work with your
vendors I'm sure they want to keep your
business and want to keep you happy and
hopefully you can stall some of your
gnarly bugs alright so just a recap here
are the suggestions I have for you
one regularly checked on your cluster
and database usage this is kind of a
no-brainer just do it even if it feels
like a pain test with a smaller dataset
especially if you're working with PI
spark because you'll end up saving money
and being able to debug your code more
easily partition your data correctly and
again the advice we've heard from data
bricks was no more than 256 megabytes
per partition run each PI spark
calculation steps separately so trigger
your transformation so you can make sure
everything is happening the way you
expect it to
additionally save your intermediate
steps to s3 so you have them later to
look at if you can avoid JDBC connectors
if you can't try and get rid of them
immediately by writing your results to
s3 or some other cheap storage and
finally if these six things don't work
then work with your vendors and check
for any unexposed third-party settings
for example secret vendor timeouts so
you may think this is kind of a downer
of a talk that has a relatively happy
ending this is our CFO ozone ozone
worked with my boss to get a chunk of
the money I spent on data breaks back
from snowflake since it was ultimately
their time out that was at fault and
they did this by threatening to go back
to redshift which is my favorite part of
this whole story
all right so thank you all for listening
thank you to shop earner for letting me
spend a munch of money and then paying
me to come talk about it thanks to the
data science team Michaelangelo Hannah
ally Russia and Scott
some of them lived through this with me
they all gave me feedback on the slides
and the proposal Hannah and Allie are
talking later they have really good
talks too tuturro dhoka also helped me
with the proposal insights Thanks
[Applause]
questions I guess
what we were working with data bridge so
we weren't controlling our a safety
right but I mean he didn't think I was
gonna spend too much I guess I haven't
set up a cloud team
what's a lesson learned from a very
young age of knights - yeah
yes there's a lot of things we could
have done differently
yep it snowflake didn't have a 60-minute
setting in place wouldn't you just not
spending that money like having jobs run
forever
yes yeah so the having that 60 minute
limit in place actually helped us figure
out what the bug is so you're right we
would have just kept spending money our
jobs would have finished though so at
one point they did increase the limit
for us and I was able to get a job to
finish and then we also started doing
like this writing to s3 stuff as well so
it's based on real events maybe not in
the exact sequence they happened yep I
may be missing something and safely told
you suggest that you didn't use the JDBC
connection data bricks yeah I was gonna
ask what are they suggesting you use
instead what so data brick sirs told us
to you immediately write to s3 and then
work with the data from there so there's
like just use it once yes okay well
initially they told us not to use the
connector but obviously that's not
practical
all right thanks I'll be around
[Applause]